[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
bluetooth reports
pre-game picks what's going on we are
live from boston massachusetts with a
good one tonight
as always we are the show that gives you
the people at home a chance to take home
free cash prizes by
simply predicting the random [ __ ] that
occurs in the nba pregame and we know
a lot of random [ __ ] occurs we got a
jam-packed night tonight we gave away a
lot of money last week we're gonna do
the same this week so let's get to the
picks
baby lois was popping you dirty
what's talking dog when i don't famous
lost i'm in the building
let's get it boom i told you how crazy
is that wait is that a three
that's that three step curry wow
money i told y'all welcome to pregame
picks let's get it
hey as always i am your host pierre aka
p with a plug this is pre-game picks and
i'm with my boy
famous lost lois who's popping with you
bro what's up pete what's up how you
feeling today
hey i'm feeling good living better you
know i missed you we was we was going
for a minute this ain't been that weak
exchange it was a little short
but we're here we here laughed from
boston oh yeah we lost
we lost we lost some time didn't we yeah
yeah we lost an hour it's awesome we did
and i ain't okay i need that time back
well hey before we even get to what we
got to get to
before we get to all that and we're
giving out the money to the people in
the comments so y'all make sure y'all
stay active and stay put
but while we in boston shout out to the
goat i heard that lebron is the owner
part owner of the red sox now the boston
red sox
how you feeling about rich real quick
he's rich
he's rich that let you know how rich he
is and
and that came out of nowhere and that
came out of nowhere did not worry
anything about that
i i had i had no clue it was just
breaking news on my phone
i didn't see that coming from my mind
shout out to the goat
i'm telling y'all but i know something
well no brian got
brian got sources we can't reach telling
you
hey is lebron yo go i can't remember is
lebron you'll go up
you older than me so jordan might be
your goat i can't remember
hey uh you
funniest hell nah magic johnson
first no uh mj is the goat
but magic johnson kobe and stephen curry
are my goats
and drake oh wow wow
wow okay i don't need one i'm not even
i'm not even going to start with you on
that subject today i'm not that that's
ridiculous
but to each other though i'm confused
what are you talking about
i'm confused listen
today we ran a poll or we were in a
question before the show started
all the jazz legit championship
contenders before lost even speaks his
piece on this i want y'all in the
comments to let us know
what y'all thinking which all opinions
is lois talk to me
are the jazz a real contender i mean
they're not fake
what's their record they're like 20 like
they haven't even lost 10 games have
they
they haven't lost 10 games right they're
like twenty eight and nine
this is why they're gonna be straight
look
yeah damn their tip yeah it's damn near
damn but it's still
under 10. they have not lost 10 games
this is why they're gonna be straight
because because because two players
don't gotta just
come out there and then everybody don't
got to jump on their back and they gotta
they gotta average 30.
they gonna be good because everybody do
their part everybody
everybody average about 18 and donny
averaged about 20 something then
you got jordan clarkson boo boo he has
about 20 18
19. i'm like boy what you got uh you got
joe black
joe black out there colin come on bro
this is why they good because they moved
they look like people be killing me but
they look like the old warriors the way
they move the ball and shoot threes
the way they move the ball and shoot
threes the way they shoot the ball
is and make three all right the way they
move the ball then this makes it really
simple
since lebron ain't one of your goats
he's one of my goats
and and and before i even respond i'm
like no lebron
no oh oh did i not say the boy lebron
one of my goats
he's one of my goats you okay i messed
up he's one of my goats
he okay okay well this is what this is
what my goat had to say about the jazz
during all-star weekend when he was
drafting his all-star team roll that
footage please
i just i just want to say something
because
there's no slander there's no slander to
the utah jazz but you guys got to
understand
you guys got to understand just like in
video games growing up
we never played with utah even as great
as carl malone
we would have never picked
hey so with lebron saying that although
that could be very irrelevant in the
grand scheme of winning a championship
who plays with who on 2k might not even
matter
but yeah do you does he have a point or
you ain't trying to hear that [ __ ]
what that ain't that ain't got nothing
to do with the real life
i thought he was just talking about the
game what they got to do in real life
but what he's saying is those pla it's a
reason why they you know what i'm saying
they ain't got that
it they ain't got that it factor that's
what i think he's trying to allude to
he's saying i think he's serious
you're not seriously sitting up here
with a straight with a straight face
telling me
he said they don't have it because no
one picks them
on 2k no no he's saying they don't
he's saying they don't have it so people
don't pick them
because they don't have that it's [ __ ] i
personally don't think the jazz are a
championship contender i think they're a
sexy team
they're having a great regular season
but i don't think they won't smoke with
any of them big dogs
at all i just like i just like i just
like that they play team ball
i just like that they play team ball and
then got to count on somebody to score
40 every night
which people just don't be doing so it's
kind of easier to play like that
so everybody and they and their
possessions be long as hell and they'd
be moving that ball
hella fast don't nobody want to play
that much damn defense in the league and
that's the
you know don't buy one after about four
rotations damn i'm over it
[ __ ] i'm over it after four rotations
and that's how they gonna feel too
that's why the jazz only love watching
games
i i love watching that style of
basketball but
sometimes you do got to have that that
do even if you can win games without
needing them and i would love to see
what y'all are saying in those comments
can we pop some of them comments up on
my screen so we can see what they say
please bring them up please bring him up
but
every once in a while you do need that
you do need that dude that can go get
you that 40. and
and donovan can but their second best
player is rudy
sometimes he don't play utah wait wait
wait wait wait
mike mike connolly mike conley mike
conley mike connolly is not the second
best
player he's i thought it was rudy
goldberg
no because they don't have a true
superstar somebody said they don't have
a true superstar and they tell you how
you feel about that lois
why don't they how much do uh how much
do
doc how about a dollar a minute your
average
uh donovan mitchell is probably like a
23 point score this year 24 point score
about about 23 what brian average i
could get you to
i can get you the for sure the for sure
numbers right now
yeah 24.8 lebron eric
how you feeling 27. so so lebron
listen wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait so so so donovan aaron is 25
and the best player in the world
averages 27
and he's they don't have a go-to killer
like that i'm confused no no no no they
didn't
they didn't say go-to they said a
superstar a superstar
what is it based off how many points you
score do you think donavan mitchell is a
superstar you think donovan mitchell is
there
i mean if you want if you want to start
throwing all these terms out here
it gets kind of lovely but we're talking
about we're talking about a team
i'm just saying i'm just saying we're
talking about a team that plays
basketball together bro that [ __ ] gets
scary
that's it you're scared when you got to
watch when that
when when this when jordan clarkson
might be 40
when you worry about donovan mitchell
and mike carley and rudy gobert
but but but but but jordan might get you
40. that [ __ ] gets scared sometimes you
get mind-boggling
don't deal with it so since they could
since they can shoot the three balls so
well and that's your point we might as
well roll into the first challenge
will donovan mitchell make more threes
and warm-ups than jayson tatum
that's our first challenge who makes
more threes and warmups
donovan mitchell or jason tatum who you
rolling with and i want the people at
home to know
we are we are picking winners and losers
so whatever you pick if you're right
you're going to take a chance you're
going to have
a chance to take home 500 on this first
challenge
if you write no matter which way you
pick whichever the right answer is is
what gives you a chance
to take home 500 so i i don't know if
you want to listen to lost i don't know
if you want to listen to me i don't know
if you want to listen to us both but we
have the same i'm trying to win
what do you have i'm trying to win them
the money who do you want to win on the
money so
so donovan
donny bravo oh wait
it's who makes more who takes more it's
who makes me
think you you're a hooper you
you're a hooper you know we only can't
we don't care about taking
we on the count whenever yeah sir uh uh
let's go with uh
let's go with uh i'm gonna go with donny
donnie bravo cause he's probably gonna
take more because jt got to work on the
fade too
oh see now that that's why that's that's
why i'll be rocking with lois that's why
i'll be rocking with lois and paying
attention to what he's saying and what
he's looking at
because that's a good point i want to
rock with tatum
but you're right tatum gonna do a lot of
in-between [ __ ] which could take away
from the opportunity to take threes
cause y'all know tatum lud he loved
tough tough difficult jump shots in that
mid-range area
i mean donnie donnie gonna be throwing
some floaters too though
donnie gonna gonna throw some floaters
too but jt gotta get that mid-range
right too
because donnie gonna take a lot of
threes and dunks
no for sure me me and lois we agreeing
on this one we agreeing on this one we
taking donovan mitchell
so i want y'all at home to put in the
comments what y'all taking
and if y'all think we're wrong and y'all
taking tatum please let us know why
because i would love to know why
y'all would take jason tatum over
donovan mitchell knowing
that jason tatum gonna do some extensive
mid-range work
trade deadline is looming around los
these are two teams we need
who are in the playoffs now we need
brian
we need bond who need bra
hey boy all week is hell right there boy
oh man the man got the jersey
by his side at all times listen you
really want brian to come over there and
take steph curry shine
all right then that's what i think hey
we got the boys coming to the court
can't nobody because can't nobody take
no okay nobody take my dog
stop it hey no hey that may be a fact
cause we saw kd got up out of there
quick and
quick and quicken in a hurry no
disrespect katie even he got his ass
spotted there
once he saw that nobody was gonna take
away curry light
but remind everybody that's
the challenges does not start till both
teams
are on the floor and both players are
shooting and the challenge does not
end until the both teams are done
or which whenever somebody leaves the
court so if if
if they're shooting and donovan mitchell
decides to leave early it's cut there
they got to start and somebody got to
leave for it to be done
if not we'll go to whole warm-up and
last week i was getting a lot of
messages
about people talking about how to get
their money when you do win money if
you're one of those people that's picked
to take money you got to get on that
bleach report app
and check your dms i promise you that
500 or 200
depending on which one you win or maybe
both will be there
give the br team some some time we gonna
get your paper
trust and believe now we have the boston
celtics coming to the floor
lost i hope man letting them people down
but no but
really what do the boston celtics need
to be
to be a team that they want to be they
they've had like
high aspirations but they ain't ever
been there yet
what are they lacking to you a stupid
big
a stupid big man like a like a cold big
man
i don't not not they don't need like no
joke no no joking but they need at least
something like
um damn
who was i about to say he was with
houston last week
somewhere else yeah they got they got
jake
listen listen yeah yeah yeah they need
something like like capella or something
like that because they got
kimba jalen tatum like damn if they get
another guard
damn kimmel at 60 last year i mean two
years ago with uh
with with charlotte come on now then jb
playing out his mind then jt
they don't need to worry about the guard
stuff they need they need a big that's
going to
do something like i don't know scare
people or something
we're still waiting on jason tatum to
hit the floor ladies and gentlemen
what about nicola lucevic from orlando
you rock revulsive
what if he was with boston how good
would they be then
man i'm gonna be watching them bigs like
that but i did watch one game he was
tortured
but that was against y'all then he get
did he get a warriors that business
i think he gave a warrior it might have
been this i'm not mistaken that might
have been us
no that might have been us he might have
been dogging us alone
look at donovan i hate donovan well 45
oh the only thing i hate about
donovan what's your name 45
no it's not even that i don't like it
but it's like a guard like i ain't never
seen like a guard with 45.
hey your boy your boy is why guards wear
the big numbers
no i take that back jason williams white
chocolate he used to wear 55
but curry curry with the 30. 30 with you
know
but white chocolate did worth 55. you
know yeah
yeah no 30 was different 30 was
different look hey look at donny already
taking threes already remember what i
said don't forget are we keep are we
keeping count i don't see no numbers
no i don't see nothing we waiting on
tatum
they don't know that no it don't
somebody said tatum got a fade if so he
taken it
they said depending on what haircut
jason tatum got they picketed him
hey there we go he got the fade there we
go
he got the face there we go
i think he's been on that floor well
taco black is hell
taco boy hey hey i i got i got word that
our director loves taco fall it's a big
taco i don't know
hey look look and hey look and people
people be thinking i'm crazy i swear
i was saying they need to play taco i
forgot they got taco
i said they need to play taco a little
bit dang every time he get in he get
three
no for for real for real why yeah why
don't why don't taco play at all like i
ain't saying he got to play 40 minutes
but yeah he don't play at all
what's with that wow he get what's wrong
with come on he get he get 20
he gonna get he need 20 minutes a game
18 20
20 minutes a game damn like not no cash
why do they not play him we had we had
uh
on my podcast we had uh we had taco
following up here good dude
shout out to taco he big as hell which
yeah i'm sure everybody understand he
big but
you don't really understand i took a
picture i took a picture with him
yeah hit his head across them
your [ __ ] so we got zero zero nobody
made it three yet
nobody definitely made a few threes
donnie definitely made a few threes
okay mitchell just made one we got one
on the board for donovan
hold on what's up what's up what
hey hold on i'm getting relaxed my my my
people gonna get it right give them some
time give them a little minute they
gonna get it right
they gonna get it right don't worry
i'm just anxious yeah i'm trying to win
people money i'm just anxious
no i i just got word in my ear that one
one of uh mitchell shots was a mid-range
shot
hey a discussion that i'll be seeing a
lot on twitter every time
the celtics play is jaylen brown
is is jaylen brown a true number one
or number two to you
i mean we're the average
i can't tell you what he averaged the
top of my head he's a 20 plus point
scorer though 20
probably 20 you said 21 22.
i think it's more i think it's more than
21.
i think it's one or two in the one 24.3
24.3 24.3 you just yo you just answered
you asked you answered your own question
what you mean is he a true one too
you answered your own question he
averaged twenty-four point three that
really mean he putting up twenty
twenty eight a night look look look what
he doing the taco what
the hell hey what what i better tell you
what i'm telling you
what do that what do that mean though
because i know what i've seen a lot of
dudes average
20 numbers numbers i mean numbers
numbers show for themselves
number show for themselves bro like i
don't it doesn't matter about his name
it doesn't matter what his name is yo
his he
he he averaged 24 point boom it doesn't
matter if he has a pop-up so let me
answer this question
let me ask you this question speak for
yourself somebody asked you this
question
it's jeremy graham this basketball is on
twitter is
is jeremy grant a true number one then
what what what what what what jeremy
grant and again
detroit because it should have stayed at
um
it should have stayed at um should have
said that
endeavor he's not the 20-plus point
scorer that he is now
that's my point with denver a playoff
team he was coming off the bench
now he go to detroit need a 20 20-plus
point score
so is he a true okay i'll
no so who are we talking about so how
much he averaged we might find it
so yeah it's the difference between 20
plus we just said
jalen 20. you know 24 24
jeremy graham i'm gonna let you know 32
to 23.
yeah cause i'm gonna let you know what
he missing
he is he's average of 23 point points a
game
that just ain't it that ain't gonna that
ain't gonna cut it that just ain't gonna
cut it
that's a point below jayla brown
and and yeah and he and we said it was
here one or two
but that ain't gonna cut it when you're
right hey look but it's two it's two oh
no okay oh no no no listen little listen
listen before we even said it
this is this is the difference this is
the difference yes that's dana brown
but he has he has jalen he has he has
jason tatum with him
doing the same [ __ ] or better and then
he has a kimball right there too
so when you're doing that yes it's it's
it matters when you have help so
yeah you're true you he's the truth
number one
can a team you can be successful with
with jaylen brown as they number one
or number two option and i'm talking
about a success success yes not this
middle of the pack boston
boston celtic [ __ ] i'm talking with
him averaging 25 points
yes with him averaging 25 points yes sir
what are you talking about he's
averaging five less points
then then then probably damien literally
to somebody but what are you talking
about
five points first fir first of all
first of all i didn't even argue with
you i'm just putting all the factuals on
the damn table
that's oh my god i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry no
i took it i took it wrong and then
number
number two the score is two to one
donovan mitchell set his ass down for a
second so hopefully he get up off that
bench and start shooting
jayson tatum seem to be playing around
smiling joking which was fine
but at some point i'm gonna need them to
ramp it up i agree with everything that
you said
i i believe that jaylen brown could beat
us the second option on a really good
team
i think boston has a brightness i think
danny age
i think danny ainge got to make a couple
tweaks in a couple moves
hopefully kimmel walker can be healthy
with that knee issue but i think they
got a bright future and i think they'd
be foolish to ever
trade one or the two i think you keep
tatum and brown together as long as you
can because that is paul
georgia kawhi of the east for sure for
sure at a younger age
but in the future but this is it if if
jeremy grant averages 23 points
the second best player on that team
gotta average 21.
and the third best player gotta have
gotta have
gotta average uh 18. they have to have
the same [ __ ]
that's going on that jazz that the jazz
have going on
that's why the jazz is successful right
now donovan mitchell averages like 24
points 25 points
and the second best player averages boom
boom and then
the the sixth man of the year gonna
average about 18 19.
like that's you know it happens
i want to get the full spiel of the utah
jazz
and their averages as a team so you
ready i'm i'm going to tell you
everything
in order right so yeah when we talk
about points per game
obviously at 25.
jordan clarkson is right is right but
right below him at 17.9 points so he's
basically a 18 point scorer
right under him is mike conley at 16.
under him is bogdanovic at 15.
under him is ruby at 14 and under him is
joe ingles at 11.
hey that's between between uh
uh between just them three people
how many points is that you feel me
and they playing and they playing
defense between them three people you
got joy you got don
you got uh uh you said donny bravo
average 25
jc average like 18 the next person six
all right so 18 16 15
like damn that's three people it don't
use the goal like that
when when dame averaged 30 cj averaged
25
next person my average like then they
dropped next 11
yeah no for sure for sure for sure
but i'm gonna tell you why i'm gonna
tell you why i got them boys out there
in l.a because they got a dog out there
averaging 25.
they got another mug out there averaging
22.5
on a and he's just chilling that's
that's that chicago
oh anthony davis he's just chilling 22
and a half he's just chilling he just
he's coasting we ain't even seeing the
best of him yet then they got schroeder
at 14.
they got they got montrez at 14. they
got cools mad 12
and they got your boy kcp knocking on
the doe and nine points i don't think
the jazz could contend with a team i
know my book casey pedo average nine
look look at that again
look at that again i know what what
casey i was
at least 11. he he averaged he averaged
8.9 he's a nine point scorer this year
shout out to kcp man shout out to kcp we
got tatum
tatum up right now lois donovan mitchell
got
he got to get up off that bench and quit
playing man three yeah
i told y'all but look hey look hey look
my people they went with me they really
cheated us cause
cause donny donny donny took 23s before
they counted
hey my people in my ear telling me it
only count when they both won the court
at the same time we can't give donovan
mitchell a head start
but i know i know this is the time for
donovan mitchell to catch up because
jason tatum working on mid-range like
you said
i just seen donovan knock one down
that's two that's two let's change that
i'm looking at him right now
yes sir here in the corner now and he
got his jersey off so he really about to
go three-point contest with it
hey get my boy the ball where the ball
is pause where the ball boy is bro
somebody's about to get five come on now
come on now who's
saying them at four well jt oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god y'all see
that boy you see that shimmy
hey tatum did not drink potatoes
jason tatum he might have threw one up
jason tatum or brandon ingram
tell me that tell me your two duke boys
answer me that the two dude boys
two jason two new boys you can't make me
do that
you can't make me do that two dude boys
never go against the grain
come on now better forget but if we get
tougher
but but okay if we get tougher than that
i gotta go north carolina what you
talking about boy don't play with me
you're talking north korea i love it i
love diversity i'm glad you answered
everybody
while we are keeping track of this close
three-point competition between jason
tatum and donovan mitchell i must remind
all of y'all at home
that we are also waiting to see the
result of the last shot of the jazz
warm-up
will it be a make or a miss y'all in the
comments let us know
and you can get a chance to take home
200 for that second
challenge so make sure y'all getting
your answers in everybody who voted on
this first challenge make sure y'all get
your answers in as well
for a chance to win 500 loss let's go
we might be sending some people home
with some money donovan taking off i
told you
hey if you want to win your bread and
some toast vote with lows
if you want to win bread and toast go
with lows
yeah i got to come up with my slogan now
if you want if you want to take home
that cheese you better roll with pee
hey hey hey
hey when we gonna do it real you just
made me mad
when you gonna let when you're gonna uh
when you're gonna come buy a verse from
me
i'll be i was just in the scoop hey hey
y'all you funny as hell
hey yo hey chicago got the best uh they
got the best convenience yeah that man
said where you gonna come out
10 seconds left we got we got mitchell
up eight
we bout to send some people boys went
fast as hell
i told y'all if you want to win your
bread and your toast
you gotta roll with lows hey
but they might still be shooting
something bad going on
my my people at home on the edges they
cease they trying to get dirty
bring it back bring it back bring it
back bring it back hey
shout out to all the people in the
comments that roll with me and lose on
the doctor and mitchell pick
five of y'all will be taking home five
hundred dollars if you roll with us
so we got y'all with that don't worry
we'll announce our five in a second i
got my team right now
looking over the film trying to see for
the second match
replay right now lois let's check it out
right now and it was
how long how long was that last shot oh
mate
mate miss mit wait what the a make
that's a mate it's a mess it's a mate
he missed a three he shot that he missed
that [ __ ]
hold on last one for the all right it's
a me it's a me
they hey lois they in my ear they saying
they judging off the last shot before
the lights go off which was a make so we
will be sending five
more people home with money we got five
people going home with 500
we got 500 people going home with 200
these are our donovan mitchell
winners right here who roll with me and
lose that will be taking home five
hundred dollars tonight
we got ill 12 37 we got q todd q todd i
remember that name you've been around
for a minute
green wave 22 that mean you may be a you
may be a celtic fan green wave and then
we got
trample underfoot and gabriel
um trample on it but i don't know what
that mean but you got 500
loss shout out to you man you sending
people home with that paper
you made an excellent point man um i'm
giving back to the community
and then the last shot of the warm-ups
for the jazz maker miss the five people
that chose
make with us are taking home 200 we got
kylan
carr hope i'm saying the name right we
got spicy dubs we got mark
and we got a couple others make sure
y'all checked on bleach report dm so you
can get your cash money again a recap we
had
donovan mitchell making more threes and
warm-ups and jayson tatum and we have
the jazz
ending warm-up with a made basket and by
listening to me and lose
we send 10 people home with cash money
loss
it's always good doing this with your
brethren yes sir
hey man hey i wait for this man keep
sending up
kim keep sitting on people home with
that paper we gonna see them next week
hey come back first lois i'm in the
studio get with me
okay stop yeah
2500 a word
[Music]
do
[Music]
alright
[Music]
you